>>> THIS MORNING NEW DETAILS
ALSO FROM THE AFFIDAVIT OFFER
REALLY A MUCH CLEARER PICTURE
INTO WHAT HAPPENED ON THE NIGHT
OF THE MURDER OF THE FOUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN IDAHO.
WE ALSO LEARNED ABOUT A
SURVEILLANCE OPERATION THAT LED
TO THE ARREST OF THE SUSPECT
THAT WAS SEEN PLACING GARBAGE
BAGS INTO NEIGHBORS' BINS.
JOHN AVLON IS WITH US.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THE AFFIDAVIT SAID SO MUCH
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T KNOW HOW MUCH
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY GOT TO THIS
SUSPECT AND WHY.
>> THE AFFIDAVIT IS THE ANATOMY
OF A COMMON CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
OVER THE LAST SEVEN WEEKS WE
HEARD PEOPLE SAY THE CASE ISN'T
GOING ANYWHERE, THE POLICE
AREN'T TELLING US ANYTHING, WHY
ISN'T THIS SOLVED ALREADY.
BUT THE AFFIDAVIT TELLS US FROM
THE DAY OF THE MURDER, START
WITH THE VIDEO CANVAS AND
DEVELOP PICTURES OF A WHITE
HYUNDAI ELANTRA.
IT'S A CAR, NOT A PERSON, THEY
DON'T HAVE A PLATE.
THEY ASK OTHER POLICE
DEPARTMENTS TO LOOK FOR THAT
CAR.
COLLEGE POLICE OFFICER FINDS
ONE, THEY THEN LOOK AT THE OWN
EROF THAT CAR.
ON DECEMBER 23rd THEY GET THE
CELL PHONE RECORDS SHOWING THE
OWNER OF THAT CAR HAS BEEN WHAT
APPEARS TO BE FROM THE RECORDS
STAKED OUT IN THE AREA OF THAT
MURDER HOUSE A DOZEN TIMES SINCE
AUGUST.
SO THEY START TO ZERO IN ON
BRYAN KOHBERGER.
BUT WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
AFFIDAVIT, THE CHILLING DETAILS,
DOWN STAIRS SURVIVING WITNESS
HEARS CRYING UPSTAIRS AND A
VOICE SAYING IT'S OKAY I'M HERE
TO HELP YOU, THE DOG BARKING,
MORE CRYING.
AND THEN SEES A FIGURE CLAD IN
BLACK WALK THE DOOR THROUGH THE
SLIDING GLASS WEARING A BLACK
MASK IT'S FRIGHTENING TO READ.
>> IT TURNS OUT AS PEOPLE WERE
SAYING -- I GUESS EVERYONE SORT
OF THOUGHT WHAT'S GOING ON?
DOESN'T ANYONE KNOW ANYTHING?
ISN'T THERE ANY EVIDENCE?
TURNS OUT THERE WAS A LOT THEY
WERE WORKING ON THAT WE WEREN'T
AWARE OF.
>> A LOT.
I'VE BEEN IN CASES LIKE THIS
BEFORE, WHERE YOU HAVE GREAT
LEADS AND THEY FIZZLE AND THEN
OTHER LEADS WORKING AND ONE OF
THEM STARTS TO PAN OUT.
S IT WAS A LOT OF EVIDENCE BUT
IT CAME IN BITS AT A TIME AND
TWO DAYS BEFORE CHRISTMAS REALLY
ACCELERATES.
BUT SOME OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS THAT HAVEN'T COME OUT IN
THE AFFIDAVIT, THEY'RE STAKED
OUT IN PENNSYLVANIA AT BRYAN
KOHBERGER'S HOUSE AT -- AT HIS
FAMILY'S HOUSE AT A RURAL AREA.
AND THE SURVEILLANCE TEAM
WATCHING FROM A PRETTY GREAT
DISTANCE SEES HIM COME OUT AND
CLEAN THE CAR FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM, INSIDE AND OUT, USING
SURGICAL GLOVES TO HANDLE ITEMS
AS IF THE CAR WAS ABOUT TO BE
SOLD ALMOST.
THEY SEE HIM TAKING OUT THE
TRASH AT 4:00 IN THE MORNING.
BRYAN KOHBERGER HIMSELF.
AND THEN PUTTING IT IN THE
NEIGHBOR'S BIN NEXT DOOR.
WHY IS HE UNDER SURVEILLANCE?
ONE THEY'RE WAITING TO GET
PROBABLE CAUSE TO ARREST HIM SO
HE DOESN'T GET AWAY, DISAPPEAR,
THEY DON'T HAVE TO FIND HIM.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THEY'RE
THERE TO SEE IF THEY CAN RECOVER
THAT ABANDONMENT SAMPLE
SOMETHING HE THREW AWAY THAT
WOULD HAVE HIS DNA ON IT THAT'S
WHY THEY WENT TO THE TRASH,
COLLECTED IT AND TESTED IT THAT
ALLOWED THE JUDGE TO OKAY THE
WARRANT.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING,
MOTIVE.
>> WE STILL DON'T HAVE MOTIVE.
THE CLUE TO THAT IS NOT ONLY IN
THE AFFIDAVIT BUT POPPY, THEY
CAME OUT, THE DAY THEY ANNOUNCED
THE ARREST AND SAID, WHO KNOWS
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS GUY WHO CAN
SHARE IT WITH US?
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL TRYING TO
GET INTO THAT.
ONE OTHER THING THAT NOBODY HAS
TALKED ABOUT.
PENNSYLVANIA AUTHORITIES ARE
LOOKING AT THIS CASE THAT
HAPPENED ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE COUNTRY BUT SAYING THIS GUY
LIVED HERE.
AND BASED ON THE OFFENDER
CHARACTERISTICS OF QUADRUPLE
MURDER DONE WITH SOME EFFICIENCY
IN THE DARK, THEY DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IS HIS FIRST ENCOUNTER WITH
VIOLENCE.
MOST KILLERS DON'T START OFF
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> SO THEY'RE GOING BACK THROUGH
UNSOLVED CASES IN PENNSYLVANIA
TO SAY WHAT FITS THE MO, THE
PATTERN, THE OFFENDER
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE CRIME
SCENE TO SEE DO WE HAVE AN
UNSOLVED CASE THAT FITS HERE
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE THINGS WE
DIDN'T HAVE, A NAME, DNA, THINGS
TO COMPARE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
JOHN MILLER, THANK YOU.